ce sont les premiers bombardements sur
la capitale depuis la mi avril
et c'est cet immeuble résidentiel qui a
été détruit par un missile dont je fais
le mauvais bouton j'ai entendu une
première explosion très forte nul 17
femmes puis une autre j'ai eu très peur
c'était comme les bombardements de la
deuxième guerre mondiale vingt autres
activités internet au cateau
dadaab est elle un appartement un peu
plus loin
on a senti notre immeuble bougeait je
croyais qu'il allait s'effondrer dit
elle j'ai pensé ça y est on va mourir
cet édifice intéressant seuls les étages
du bas étaient déjà habitées
et c'est là dans les décombres que les
secouristes ont découvert le corps de la
journaliste ukrainienne virag itx elle
travaillait pour radio liberté un média
financé par les etats-unis oyo ici une
clinique dentaire n'avait pas encore
ouvert ses portes l'équipement n'est pas
trop touché mais c'est un dur coup pour
le propriétaire
quand que c'est terrible pour nous dit
il pour notre pays pour notre famille il
faut tout recommencer
malgré tout la russie affirme avoir
plutôt tout celle usines d'armement
situé juste à côté
forces russes ont détruit avec des armes
de haute précision de longue portée les
ateliers de l'entreprise spatiale artiom
a déclaré le porte-parole du ministère
russe de la défense c'est un choc pour
beaucoup des résidents des alentours
parce qu'il commence à peine à revenir
dans la ville après le retrait des
forces russes du nord du pays un rappel
que même s'ils sont rentrés chez eux ils
ne sont pas à l'abri pataud n'y a pas
que des heureux puisque d'irma léopold
kolk les russes font ça partout nous dit
larissa à mario paul à quartier va bout
de chat ils s'en prennent aux civils
elle nous montre sur son téléphone la
maison d'une de ses amies brooke et
agenais dolbeau ce niveau c'est
complètement détruit il y avait deux
étages il ne reste plus rien plus rien
natalia est venu déposer quelques fleurs
une pensée pour ceux qui ont été touchés
highstreet
mkm des spurs je ne ressens que de la
haine de la colère et du désespoir dit
elle parce qu'on ne peut rien y faire
et surtout natalia c'est qu'elle même
pourrait être la prochaine victime de
ces bombardements céline galipeau
radio-canada kiev